-Welcome back.
[ Claps ]
Everybody!
Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
[ Claps ]
We love songs.
We especially love songs
written by our audience members.
[ Claps ]
In under an hour.
Ah, gotcha!
It's time for "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Here we go!
-♪ Writing a song
and singing the song ♪
♪ And writing a song
about another song ♪
-Welcome to "Battle of the
Instant Songwriters."
Before the show,
we went through our audience
and we picked out two people who
said that they were musicians.
And we gave them each
made up a so--
a made-up song title
to each of them -- okay? --
and gave them one hour
to write an original song
based on that title.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage a minute ago.
This is real.
Yeah.
Let's see
what they come up with.
Let's meet our contestants.
Come on over, everyone.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to see you.
How are you?
Hey, nice to see you, bud.
Welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-Let's start
with contestant number one.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name's from Katie Martucci.
I'm from West Hurley, New York.
-West Hurley, New York!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shout-out to Dottie and Tommy.
I love West Hurley, New York.
What is the title of the song
that you were given?
-My song is called "Filled my
Hot Tub with Pumpkin Spice."
-Ah, we gave you
a good one there.
Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-What instrument will you be
playing tonight?
-The guitar.
-Oh. Well, please,
go get ready on stage.
Thank you very much
for being here, Katie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Katie, this is very exciting.
And now, ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform
the world premiere
of the soon-to-be-classic
"Filled my Hot Tub
with Pumpkin Spice,"
it's Katie Martucci.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Feel the crisp in the air ♪
♪ Summer's come to an end,
and it's time to prepare ♪
♪ Got my sweater, got my plaid ♪
♪ Just one thing
that I'm missing ♪
♪ And it's driving me mad ♪
♪ I want someone ♪
♪ I want you ♪
♪ And I think I know
just what to do ♪
♪ Don't go to Starbucks ♪
♪ Come to mine ♪
♪ 'Cause I fill my hot tub
with pumpkin spice ♪
♪ Why do you look
so surprised? ♪
♪ You know it's gonna be
so nice ♪
♪ Sweeter than pie ♪
♪ So come soak with me
under the leaves ♪
♪ Bubbles between you and I ♪
♪ Pumpkin spice ♪
♪ You and I ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
That's actually...
Katie Martucci!
That was incredible.
Oh, you made it sound beautiful.
How'd you do that?
-[ Laughs ]
-That's almost impossible to do.
All right.
Uh, good luck.
[ Laughter ]
Contestant number two,
what is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name is Sean McVerry.
I'm from Middlebury,
Connecticut.
-Yeah, Sean McVerry!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Middlebury, Connecticut.
Sean, tell everybody
what your song title is.
-My song is called
"Fantasy Football,
Regular Life."
[ Laughter ]
-What instrument
will you be playing tonight?
-I'm playing the piano.
-Sean, take the stage
and get ready.
Get prepared.
This is an experience.
Get in the zone.
Channel that inspiration, Sean.
Ladies and gentlemen,
get ready for the world premiere
of "Fantasy Football,
Regular Life," by Sean McVerry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I've got Aaron Rogers ♪
♪ As my first-round pick ♪
♪ Hanging in my apartment
with my roommate Rick ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I catch a pizza bagel
in my mouth ♪
♪ And I get a high-five ♪
♪ Fantasy football,
regular life ♪
♪ High stakes
at the Sunday games ♪
♪ In these players
I place my trust ♪
♪ A quarterback back
in the prime of his life ♪
♪ And I come to
covered in Dorito dust ♪
♪ Sometimes I wonder if ♪
♪ They'd ever switch places
with me ♪
♪ Probably not, definitely not ♪
♪ But a boy's got to dream ♪
♪ Until then,
I focus on my draft ♪
♪ And I'll have a good time ♪
♪ Fantasy football,
regular life ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yo!
Are you kidding me?!
Well done.
-Thank you very much.
-Sean McVerry!
Both of you.
Oh, my God!
Well done!
That was awesome.
That might be the best one
we've done yet.
Now it's time to see who won.
We're gonna let our great
audience decide the winner.
[ Audience boos ]
[ Laughter ]
Unbelievable, you guys.
I enjoyed both, of course,
but there can only be one.
Was it Katie Martucci?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or was it Sean McVerry?
Sean McVerry!
Congratulations!
You are the winner!
Sean McVerry,
you will be going home
with a "I Love Music"
sweatshirt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
-Thank you so much.
-Also, you'll be going home
with a Samsung Galaxy Book2 Pro
to write and record more songs.
-Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You got that hot tub.
-Yeah.
-No.
No one goes home empty-handed.
Of course,
our other contestant will get
an "I Love Music" sweatshirt,
as well.
-Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And we're gonna give you
the Samsung Galaxy Book2 Pro.
Thank you so much.
Both, amazing jobs.
Give it up for your two new
instant songwriters!